auf und davon
mit der mobile versicherungen und
vorsorge
[Musik]
sie alle gingen auf und davon
seit über einem jahr nun leben unsere
auswanderer in ihrer neuen heimat
wie haben sie ihr erstes jahr in der
fremde erlebt sind sie heimisch geworden
wir haben sie nochmals besucht
[Musik]
alles begann mit einem traum eine post a
damit gästehäusern restaurant und pool
mitten in der weite von uruguay ein
neues projekt für die zweite
lebenshälfte
während es bei uns lebten susanne und
ruhe die im container direkt auf der
baustelle die familie almeyda austoben
tal gab ihr florierendes bed and
breakfast weiter und so mit ihren drei
kindern an die westküste kanadas in der
provinz nova scotia übernahm sie ein
modell aus den 60er jahren
alles muss der perfekt sein
trotz hochsaison renovierten sie
sämtliche zimmer des hotels
leben an der nordsee familie kunz aus
dem baselbiet übernahm eine imbissbude
direkt am meer
auch oma susanne und die zwillinge timo
und muri wanderten mit aus nur der
älteste sohn blieb zurück wie geht s
familie kunst und den anderen
auswanderern heute
[Musik]
herbst 2020 die ganze nacht ist kevin
der älteste sohn der familie kunst durch
geblockt in einem stück von basel bis an
die nordsee
einige male schon ist er die strecke
rauf und runter gefahren
doch die heutige ankunft
oft ist eine ankunft für immer
auch kevin will an der nordsee heimisch
werden
doch kaum angekommen macht der vater
druck kevin wird sofort im imbisswagen
gebraucht 12 jetzt gerade der
mineralisierung der vorbote
so ist es nicht langweilig wie jetzt ist
nicht das kauf ich musste noch plate
slush eis muss zeigt doch das gaben
jetzt noch an
muss es gab keine träne familie und
familien norbert das muss man gar nicht
drin
unser sound big bosse ist zwar da wo
wirtschaft mannschaft das schafft und es
ist ganz der musik wäre das leben hebel
job und geld
am kutterhafen zehn minuten von zu hause
entfernt steht kunz imbissbuden der
küsten imbiss
[Musik]
klamotten das gleich jetzt da nein
schnitt okarina truppen unter uns lieber
jetzt ja da hast
es ist gut dass nicht mit dem first bald
und wir stimmen unsere kraft mit
rembrandt ich bin mit dem fuß traf
andere haben obwohl noch keine kunden
vor dem wagen anstehen bricht hektik aus
immer öfter der stellen kunden würste
und pommes telefonisch es wurde zeit
dass kevin ins familienunternehmen ein
steigt denn eigentlich war er fix in das
auswanderungs projekt eingeplant
so jedenfalls war es gedacht als die
familie vor über einem jahr kurz vor
ihrer auswanderung stadt schauen wir
zurück
das eigenheim in läufelfingen baselland
ist bereits verkauft
auch großmutter susan zieht mit in den
norden
sie will nach ihrem enkeln timo und
noemi schauen während deren eltern im
imbisswagen arbeiten
nebenan sortieren mutter brigitte und
tochter noemi kleider aus in ein paar
wochen sollen vater sascha und sohn
kevin gemeinsam hinter dem grill im
imbisswagen stehen so der plan ist auch
schlecht für uns und schöne ist dass man
das ganze familie könnt und danke das
ist
ein familienunternehmen also doch es
kommt anders
kevin bleibt in der schweiz
zu sehr hängt er an seinem umfeld und
seinen freunden
jasons seite das so nicht rum das ist
schon ihr auch schon sehr schlimm finden
will sind die familie und punkt im
museum ist beweglich möge aber ich habe
mich sogar jericho zwingen haben könne
dafür umso schöner dass sie jetzt
unseren reihen
ich sehe was noch eine sache sowieso da
haben die kollegen jörg wacker und die
capital bank und der rest der familie
fehlt eine skoda drei enkel und der
zitrone krischan entschluss gefasst die
kinder auf die schaluppe alkohol amex
paritätische land steht
nur noch alles ins auto packen dann geht
es für die eltern sascha und brigitte
kunz endlich los die zwillinge timo und
noemi bleiben noch bei ihrer großmutter
in der schweiz bis das schuljahr zu ende
ist und wie schwierig das ist schwierig
okay machen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
zusammen mit der großmutter kommen timo
und seine schwester noemi in sechs
wochen nach es ist nicht ganz einfach
gewesen sie sind ja doch nur 100
kilometer weit und so das ist ein
schöner moment hat man sich
verabschieden alles habe ich so gelacht
haben sie bei allem ist es schlimm sie
kraftwerk sie mir hans leiten die darin
beschriebene mache mir eine kleine
strafe oder übernehme
wir haben aber novelle schuljahres man
entweder ermögliche dass die schule
fertig machen wo ich damals gehörte
sicherlich gering sei aber eine
wahlkarte
an der nordsee gut 900 kilometer von
basel entfernt liegt tor um eine
ortschaft mit rund 3500 einwohnern
hier haben sich die baselbieter ein haus
mit drei wohnungen gekauft
endlich am ziel
nach zehn stunden auf der autobahn worte
der lappland und falco und die heilige
birma katze roxy haben die lange fahrt
gut überstanden
freunde und nachbarn erwarten sie
bereits und reform gegenüber hilft mit
seiner familie die möbel zusammenzubauen
die schweizer haben ihn vor ein paar
monaten kennengelernt als sie das haus
renoviert um zug gelungen
[Musik]
ebenso herzlich geht es weiter
die schlüsselübergabe für den
imbisswagen feiern cricket und sascha
mit einem fest
der imbisswagen steht bereits seit 25
jahren an der nordsee der vorbesitzer
gibt den schlüssel weiter unseren
betrieb abgeben an die familie kunst aus
der schweiz darf ich euch mal ja das
sind die neuen chefs und dann chef
braucht auch ein schlüssel habe ich den
beginn von so vielen dank wie man sie
hört wir kommen als der schweiz das ist
so am nächsten freitag werden wir
eröffnen
ich bedanke mich so und jetzt und vor
reisen zwischen noch einen schönen tag
[Applaus]
[Musik]
große ruftaxi schönen auftakt also es
ist wirklich
das nicht besser können
hallo hallo schlüssel haben womit der
drogengangs macht kann zu jeder route
sowie otto zu jedem zum bergsee ist oder
ob der vertrag sehe eine wahnsinnige
gedanken gemacht werden
und also hört ist einfach sensationell
also das ist familie also wirklich wie
eine familien auf der platte und das
einzige oder unsere einzige angst die
wir gerufen haben das ist gar kein thema
[Musik]
diesen sommer im emmental die uruguay
auswanderer sind auf besuch in ihrer
alten heimat für handwerker ruhe die
althaus gibt es auch hier immer etwas zu
schrauben
während ihres aufenthaltes wohnt das
ehepaar im studio ihres
einfamilienhauses
eigentlich wollten sie schon im frühjahr
auf besuch kommen
doch corona machte ihre pläne zunichte
die stand sie plötzlich das mini rock
city nächster distanz ich nach sich
riesig und sich nicht möglich
susannes vater geht es wieder besser
und so können sie den besuch bei familie
und freunden einfach nur genießen denn
das wollen wir heute drei wochen
wirklich fähig sei entsprechend ist das
eigentlich gar nicht dass man als talent
das rohr ich glaube dass ich etwas mit
doppel funktioniert nicht die emmentaler
haben eine ereignisreiche auswanderung
hinter sich
[Musik]
vor über einem jahr räumte das ehepaar
althaus sein großes einfamilienhaus in
schupbach
hier hat der ruhr die seine kindheit
verbracht seine eltern besaßen eine
schreinerei jahre lang hatte er als bau
schreiner gearbeitet später ging er mit
der swisscoy in den kosovo
die kaffeehauskette gerät die gm hofft
der luft das geschah aber darüber reden
wir springen punkte seit 30 jahren sind
susan und rudy ein paar
[Musik]
noch einmal schweizer alltag mit ihren
drei jungs genießen und events werden so
vermessen zu glauben schreibt das wort
ist kein tat aber ein bisschen erlebt
ist mit demenz der sowjetisch
gesetzliche greifbar nah ist natürlich
wie häufig mehr konstanz das auch
[Musik]
spontane zusammenkünfte die wird es
künftig nicht mehr geben
doch besucher der söhne in uruguay sind
schon fix geplant
[Musik]
der baron hat ist da aber bestreitet
gleich mitgemacht und dass er mit dem
schuh somit macht aber dass viele nicht
so häufig sie machen die usa andere
genäht oder macht man die 7
auf der südlichen halbkugel in uruguay
beginnt ende april der herbst
die zukunft von rudi und susann liegt
weit ab von der städtischen hektik
montevideos die emmentaler wandern ins
ländliche uruguay in die pampa aus
in der nähe von colonia del sacramento
haben sie ein landstück gekauft rudi ist
vorausgereist susan folgt in ein paar
wochen
fürs erste hat er ein zimmer im
städtchen gemietet kaum angekommen hat
er auch schon seine erste
planungssitzung mit dabei alex die
auswanderungs beraterin
heute hilft sie übersetzen vor zwei
jahren hatte sie den schweizern das
grundstück vermittelt zur besprechung
ist auch architekt in china gekommen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
noch einmal wollen sie die baupläne
durchgehen und änderungen vornehmen
als gelernter schreiner mit jahrelanger
erfahrung hat wo die klare vorstellungen
es macht aus den transformers ich
letztes gut
ob ich muss einfach wieder raten
einkommen sich ziehen also muss das ist
amerika nicht ausreichend zu gast sind
auch frauen also so gut dass ich meine
autorität die freundin und ich muss das
akzeptieren
so ist das im besitz der schweizer und
das musikalische material wie mir dass
ihr aber hier geht sie aber nicht
demokratisch südamerika machen es unter
tel
es ist winter in uruguay als 19 auch
ankommt gemeinsam fahren sie zum
grundstück ihren neuen dahin ist extrem
schön
er liebt das land daher sicher dass
magath mit dem ich mir ein essen
[Musik]
susan sie zum ersten mal die ruhe die
auf der baustelle vorangekommen ist
ganz wichtig bewusst worte ist mit
letzte kurve nicht sie zum grundstück
fahren denn irgendwie wirklich wirklich
traurig macht freunde zwei ausgewanderte
zürcher erwarten sie
[Gelächter]
das ist es also ihr provisorisches
zuhause ein gelber wohncontainer
[Musik]
hätte magisch in der provinz nova scotia
ist ein beliebter ausflugsort dass beim
hotel der alma das ist bestens gelegen
direkt an der hauptstraße
als die pandemie ausbrach erlitt das
geschäft einen herben dämpfer
die all my das nutzten die zeit während
des lok downs und renovierten den
frühstücksraum des hotels komplett im
sommer eröffneten sie darin ein café ein
café nicht nur für die gäste ihres
modells sondern für alle und das läuft
wie geschmiert
eigentlich hatten die alma das geglaubt
das café nebenbei betreiben zu können
doch weit gefehlt die schweizer wurden
regelrecht überrannt
besonders an den wochenenden zum brunch
ist die hölle los
dazu kommt dass die alma das hohe
ansprüche haben
ob süßes oder salziges bei ihnen ist
alles frisch zubereitet
das ist einfach größte knackpunkt die
buchstaben erfahrung bis messi
fertigkeit muss jetzt die neuen raum
gesprochen und somit platz für das hat
uns so einfach im anschluss tiere und ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die almeyda stockten ihr personal auf
doch in diesen ersten wochen seit der
eröffnung funktionieren die abläufe noch
nicht optimal
[Musik]
soviel sommer nicht komplett zufrieden
mit massa
es ist wartet sieht wo wie lange wir
haben der stadt ruft machte der
vorwochen und wie wirksam zu finden
die heiz nichtwähler fünf oder acht
serviert öfteren in ställen und wir
müssen ihnen klar dass sie nicht
aufnehmen oder so ein leben für die
langsam gestartet haben wir rufen die
kurz personal finde die alma das sind
ausgewandert in der hoffnung ihr leben
ruhiger angehen zu können und mehr zeit
für die kinder zu haben
gehen wir zurück in die schweiz als die
familie zu ihrem kanada abenteuer
aufbrach
[Musik]
noch einmal die oma umarmen
viel glück
[Musik]
a
richtige hauptstädtischen erst viel
später den ko ich glaube im winter es
müsse ja aber richtig schlecht für
michael der selig als unvorstellbar oder
sich die stars sich darum meisten
unterschätzten eigentliche der ganzen
dreck während ihrer ersten kanada ferien
vor gut drei jahren haben die amis
diesen ehemaligen bauernhof entdeckt und
gleich gekauft
wird sehr mutig ja es gibt freistoß
konnte die miete
[Musik]
bei uns ist egal
mit dem auto dauert es eine
viertelstunde nach tattoos
heute haben robin sophie und andré ihren
ersten schultag
schulleiterin holmes erwartet die
familie schon der achtjährige robin
versteht kaum ein wort
sie heißt miss heißt frau und mögliche
andere
nach
während die kinder die schule besuchen
treffen beatrice und josef den
vorbesitzer des motels das model hat 18
zimmer gut dreimal so viel wie air bed
and breakfast dass sie in der schweiz
betrieben haben
die alma das haben das modell samt
inventar gekauft
[Musik]
auch der gas an zünder war im kaufpreis
inbegriffen
weder der schweizer tourismus alles
laufen es muss alles so was sie und
alles sofort und sie doch ambri
philosophie für die muss es einfach
funktionieren da irgendwelche welche
schroth kauft hätte oder so dass das
haben wir schon die handhabe wertige
gemacht für die liegenschaft bekannt
ein vorteil gegenüber der schweiz
weiters haben hier eine angestellte
[Musik]
auch wenn noch nicht alles perfekt ist
das barrel ist bestens gebucht ein
exquisites frühstück für die hotelgäste
liegt den albers am herzen
beatrice ist gelernte köchin während der
sommerferien helfen die kinder mit trotz
hochsaison renault jetzt die familie die
gästezimmer komplett alle 18 zimmer
sollen neu eingerichtet werden
[Musik]
altes muss neuem platz machen
über 100 möbelstücke zum selber
zusammenbauen haben sie sich liefern
lassen
ich finde sehr unterschiedlich kritik
und märkte der lügt etwas gebäude kann
früheren einfach so 15 das was nicht
funktioniert hat die flippers ich habe
zu ihnen fremde augen oder riesenrad
hand und geht das nur das rechte gemacht
hat war aber die richtige mischung
gefunden wo mache und laufen
wenige tage nach der schlüsselübergabe
feiern die schweizer eröffnung probst
aber szene
das ehepaar kunz hat es gewagt die
einstigen angestellten sind unternehmer
geworden
na ja alles nicht richtig so langsam so
nervös war sascha schon lange nicht mehr
wieder öffnet die ersten eigenen pommes
neun monate nachdem die auswanderer den
imbiss in den ferien entdeckt hatten
die hafen terrasse fühlt sich immer mehr
guten appetit
[Musik]
abendstimmung am kutterhafen gut zehn
stunden standen bridget und sascha am
eröffnungstag hinter dem grill
noch aber ist nicht schluss kassensturz
662 euro haben sie eingenommen was doch
auch wirklich erreichen
und das ist nicht so
leider betrag summieren sich sehr wohl
haben das ist so das ist mit der
es wird sich speziell weil aufgrund von
corona das ist leider so aber wir sind
guten mutes und zuversichtlich
jetzt muss sascha nur noch das öl der
friteuse ersetzen
doch irgendetwas stimmt nicht mit dem
auslauf
[Musik]
das ist richtig auf ein problem sagt
ackermann
mittlerweile mache ich das sogar - und
vollgas gut läuft sogar nach fritteuse
wechsel also heute ohne probleme
im herbst wenn die alljährlichen
sturmtiefs kommen ist die saison vorbei
dann ist es zeit den küsten imbiss in
die winterpause zu entlassen
heute wollen die kunden den wagen nach
padingbüttel fahren
die reifen sind nicht mehr fahrtauglich
ich meine was ich schon alles bewusst
sie aber ja ich weiss einfach schön
gesehen hatte dass auch cannabis bleibt
das ist mir wieder motors das ist auch
kapuze war christa gute investition als
in der box ist ich sage jetzt erledigt
die software zum amboss währungskrieg
wieder geld sehen wie's empfängern
bereich media plant
das ist was anderes kapitel nachbar
andere hilft den schweizern aus der
patsche und organisiert ersatzlos im
schritttempo geht die fahrt zum
winterquartier in padingbüttel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
groß
winterpause nichts für sascha der
jungunternehmer hat bereits eine neue
idee er möchte sich einen zweiten
kleineren wagen anschaffen
so könnte er auch in der kalten
jahreszeit pommes und würste verkaufen
wie steht es heute ein jahr danach um
saschas grill unternehmen dazu später
[Musik]
sonnenschein aber nur acht grad
die erste nacht im container ist vorüber
[Musik]
bis der erste bank als steht wohnen
susan und ruhe die auf knapp 14
quadratmetern morgen aufgestanden habe
ich eine heimische sachen stecken ja
jung
warum sollte ich von mir mal verkauf
gestellt da sie sich vom emmental in die
südamerikanische pampa auch die
kategorie ist mit ausgewandert der
schacht ring aus beton ist für den neuen
brunnen ihrer pose
die ferien lodge ist nicht ihr erstes
projekt schon ihr haus im emmental im
haben die beiden eigenhändig gebaut
der brunnen soll künftig fünf pangalos
ein restaurant sowie dem swimmingpool
mit wasser versorgen konnte wird sich
wunsch haben jetzt das eigene
grundwasser war ihnen beim kauf des
landes wichtig projekte um die frau habe
mich grundwasser abpumpen
natürlich hatte das ministerium die
zahlen
die wasserqualität wird
letztendlich ist der frisch
von der krankenpflegerin zur
hilfsarbeiterin susan wird noch manche
gelegenheit haben in diese rolle
hineinzuwachsen
aber
die ist jetzt alles mit
natürlich ist es möglich nach mexiko ist
das ganze im ersten sommer ihre
auswanderung kaufen sich die althaus
einen hund ein uruguayischer simon und
später kommt die zugelaufene hunde dame
mini dazu bald schon ist der erste bank
alu fertig gebaut
in diesen wollen die althaus selber
einziehen
endlich raus aus dem container gemacht
seit tagen ist die 53-jährige am
isolieren doppelwandig
[Gelächter]
feierabend gut zehn stunden hat ruhe auf
der baustelle geschuftet
susan bereitet bereits die nacht vor
nach 30 jahren beziehungen stürzten sich
die beiden nochmals in ein gemeinsames
abenteuer und scheinen sich so nah wie
schon lange nicht mehr
[Musik]
das mit
das ist das wird eben für ihre 20
stunden zusammen sieht und so gegen das
make up und das macht es ja ich habe
dieses sollte die eines der mädchen
musste aber bei sich nicht irgendwo
sitzen seine tigers ausgeliehen als auch
die zurückgehen und die wirklich helfen
weiter
das sei sie aber das ist wahrscheinlich
etwas dran das ist erzählte stehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
abschieds in kanada beatrice fliegt in
die schweiz zum aller ersten mal
verlässt die mutter die familie für
längere zeit
sie fliegt in die alte heimat um kurz
die für weihnachtsmärkte zu backen
[Musik]
das schweizer kurz die geschäfte ist das
zweite standbein der almeyda
[Musik]
die 2
ja setzt sich ein bisschen kopfweh
machen
[Musik]
während die mutter in der schweiz wochen
lang exklusiv für das motel und die
kinder trick or treat süßes oder saures
es ist halloween die nächsten stunden
ziehen all my dass kinder mit ihren
freunden durch die nachbarschaft
[Applaus]
die zeit ohne beatrice ist für josef
immer wieder nerven aufreibend wir auch
plan haben ein paar sachen zu ledige
soft das kindergartenteam sprinter
wieder mache ausgerechnet jetzt hat sich
der elfjährige andré auch noch den arm
gebrochen so dass mit dem mit dem
anrufen andré und den und auch die
freunde immer wieder zum ganz ehrlich
sie oder das ist schon anstrengend und
auf der anderen sind ich mag seine
kinder so könne das jeder so viel polit
um sich um ihre hand als schnee sondern
um den tiefgang und dann muss glück
führen und gästen wirtschaft
ja es ist einfach denn nach wenigen
minuten
robin just go spielen trotz stört mich
bald ist es wieder da für josef
vielleicht die längsten minuten seines
lebens seit 23 jahren war er nie mehr
als drei tage von seiner liebsten
getrennt und punkte
[Musik]
die verluste
vermisst
[Musik]
die
zurück in ihrer neuen heimat uruguay zu
sein und ruhe die sind retour aus ihren
schweizer ferien einige monate schon
lebt das ehepaar nicht mehr im container
sondern im bungalow
das haus hat zwei schlafzimmer eine
kleine küche und ein wohnzimmer
schon fast fertig ist auch das
restaurant de posada casapietra damit
kommen susan und ruhe die ihrem traum
einer ferien lockt ein großes stück
näher
das wollen sie heute mit einem kleinen
essen feiern nur noch schnell die
bodenplatten aus fugen freund hahn und
seine frau andrea aus bologna
unterstützen die pousada besitzer es ist
ein einrichten und austesten
denn endlich ist das mobiliar für das
restaurant eingetroffen
und auch die küche ist eingebaut
extremes risiko dass man meiner fans
probiert wobei der husten strom mit der
arsch liest der kann in den bauch
die aktuelle situation wünsche oder
kritik ist kann dank machen in kassel wo
man arbeitet muss hauptkommissar
siegfried allen kabinen und durch seine
perfektion nicht
bevor die gäste eintrudeln macht sich
susan auf in den nahegelegenen käseladen
dem edelweiß im südlichen uruguay hatten
sich um 1860 hunderte schweizer
niedergelassen schweizer käse ist hier
deshalb immer noch kulturgut das
edelweiß hat ein kleines aber
ausgesuchtes angebot cointreau sa das us
geschäft sind sprints emmentaler und
würste alles made in dubai
[Musik]
zurück in der pousada gaza wiesbach
instinkt ist geweckt die gäste sind da
alex die auswanderungs beraterin kommt
als erster danach der holzhändler und
seine familie
alex dienste als beraterin brauchen die
auswanderer nicht mehr
sie ist eine wichtige freundin geworden
[Musik]
das restaurant ist fertig eine wichtige
etappe ist geschafft und noch viele
werden folgen
stück für stück bauen sich die althaus
eigenhändig ihr kleines paradies
[Musik]
am dorumer kutterhafen genießen brigitte
und sascha kunst ihren promistatus
viele schweizer verbringen nicht zuletzt
wegen corona ihre ferien an der nordsee
die korona pandemie hat das leben der
deutschland auswanderer gehörig
durcheinandergebracht
das gute ist es gibt keinen zwist mehr
wegen der sauberkeit von stühlen und
tischen
die sind weggepackt
[Musik]
social distance in die gäste essen
stehend oder auf dem deich
sechs lange wochen war der küsten imbiss
während des lockouts geschlossen
das heißt wir haben wirklich können wir
wieder machen oder welche hat ihr können
sie jederzeit sich ganz um motoren
hätten nicht willst und dennis schon
wirklich winter nur das ist so aber wir
haben ja glück machen
umso größer die freude und das
engagement als die beiden wieder den
grill anwerfen durften
für mich ist das eigentlich essen
gegangen ist und dementsprechend fühle
ich mich wohl und und und und gebe
eigentlich alles und gäbe dass das eine
funktioniert und dass das ein
für kunden über und es lagen richtiger
weg mit uns absolut ja wirklich mehr
kinder
wir haben uns sofort und sehr schnell
igler constance fühlen sich wohl und ihr
clan wird immer größer die mit
ausgewanderte roxy ist hochschwanger
wie viele babys es wohl sein werden
die oma bastelt mit den kindern ein
geburtsfest einfache befehle in ruhiger
und der mal ist es nach gott nehme der
wohnturm krankl auf die rentnerin ist
mit über 70 jahren ausgewandert
sie ist da wenn tochter und
schwiegersohn am grill stehen hilft bei
den hausaufgaben der enkel und kümmert
sich schon bald um einen wurf
katzenbabys juni hatte anfänglich mühe
in der neuen heimat doch etwas wichtiges
hat sie gelernt zu sich selbst stehen
[Musik]
mir geredet mich keine und so und jetzt
rede ich aber auch was ich erwarte
sprachen so kann also ich mag auch die
trainer hat nicht so viel aber ich habe
mich danach öffnen und zu und somit sind
die raus sie zu mir kommt doch als
ausrede will ich mal sagen wenn ich ein
ziel wenn ihr wisst ihr nicht vielmehr
so gemacht
oma susan hat einen guten zugang zu den
zwillingen
ja das war es ja auch wohin sie haben
nicht das größte problem schließlich im
beigeordneter klaus und das ich glaube
dass ich ja auch sehr wichtig oder
natürlicher spannung dann plötzlich
spitze in die klassische spannend
sentieren plötzlich der schweiz
das macht auch sehr spaß mit findus ist
sie halte ich für niveau aus sehr schöne
stunden
[Musik]
zurück an den kutterhafen kunden sind
oftmals die letzten die ihre blüte
schließen wie motorsägen turnieren
verhungern oder baguette unter dem arm
halten assoziieren sven es halt keine
liebe hat und meinte das ist eine der
drei mitglieder und nun seinen job macht
und sieben nicht klappe zu machen also
über hoffen und und nehmen mit was sie
noch
[Musik]
bewegt und schulen haben
um sie überhaupt weil es immer noch hier
wurde und am ende aber ist dieses
abwasser wie ich habe seit ich hier und
jetzt kommt jetzt im sommer sind viele
auch zwischen den ferien in der brd
nicht gehabt sagt rektor vor dem h da
wird jedes jahr besser und neu steht ja
auch sohn kevin hinter dem grill
damit althaus ihren einzigen bisher
fertiggestellten bungalow vermieten
könnten
ziehen sie erneut in den container
dieser ist nicht mehr ganz so gut im
schuss publizieren während der ersten
monate in uruguay lebten die beiden im
container die enge und die feuchtigkeit
im winter truppen susan aufs gemüt
die chance der kontrolle versuchszeit
das ist noch nicht probieren konnten
somit irgendwen ob das nicht doch dieser
gedanke das wird sich ob ist ja darf mit
einem container kohl werde ich nicht
alle täter fahndete sich hiernach oder
kurz situation ist anders zuvor lange
jahre schon häufig jeder grund einkaufen
auberginen salat
ich muss es so sagen monat jeden einfach
es ist schon ja
das kann man dem abbruchhaus in
[Musik]
bangalore darf es ein wenig gemütlicher
sein
dafür soll ein neuer sessel sorgen susan
ist eine geübte fotografie diese bilder
samt neuem roten fotos müssen besonders
attraktiv werden
sie sollen auf der homepage für den
bungalow werben
[Musik]
die ganze situation gerät aber ich weiß
nicht wann und in welchen quellen das
ist dass der die geldströme in hof
verschließt sich anfangs dezember oft
dir doch wann erste touristen ihre
ferien im raum gallo verbringen werden
ist ungewiss
wegen der pandemie als uruguay seit märz
die grenzen geschlossen
der tourismus ist völlig eingebrochen
die chance dass sechs autos alles
entwickelt oder entwicklung ist das
hätte aber der darf man ihr ab bis das
macht man aber vorher schon gemacht
es kann eben bis endstufe kopf stellt
und die situation aber kaum zuvor
abgestellt
sie ist mittlerweile ein teenie mit
vielen flausen geworden
besonders die schafe des nachbarn haben
es ihm angetan
damit schädigt die herde aufmischt
musste ruhe die einen elektrischen zaun
spannen einen feed
bisher hat der ruhr die nur ausgaben
doch er nimmt es mit südländischer
gelassenheit wetter schließlich sogar
nicht unbedingt die wichtige destination
neues album zu hören zu wenig oder
besten aktion auch russischer lassen
nämlich steht vor großen flügeln
orangen mandarinen zitronen und dutzende
pinien kamen die althaus auf ihren
riesigen gelände angepflanzt
[Musik]
kommt mit vor
träume erfüllen sich manchmal anders als
man denkt und manchmal sogar besser als
man sich erträumt
[Musik]
an den wochenenden grund das café am
vorabend kaufen beatrice und josef
jeweils ein und zwar in großen mengen
lieber noch einen sack dazu nehmen
höpfl ganz viel schöner ist die
frühstück für man das eigentlich noch
geschrieben
der gute ruf von almeyda speisen und
süßgebäck hat sich hingegen schnell
verbreitet an einem einzigen wochenende
verarbeitet ihre küchen crew über 400
eier
[Musik]
selbst während des lok downs durften die
schweizer das modell offen halten weil
die zimmer direkt von außen zugänglich
sind trotzdem die buchungen brachen
drastisch ein
langsam kehren die touristen nun zurück
heute ist das paar models sogar
ausgebucht
also im letzten jahr haben wir das
zweite drittel haben
ich bin so
[Musik]
baseball ist während corona die einzige
sportart die in nova scotia erlaubt ist
[Musik]
beim training können die spieler
genügend abstand halten
[Musik]
andrä und robin trainieren zweimal in
der woche weiter statt immer grüßt
junior days
[Musik]
zuerst war der lockdown jetzt sind
sommerferien
über fünf monate haben die kinder keine
schule mehr besucht endlich können all
my dass mehr zeit mit ihnen verbringen
das einzig gute an den pandemie monaten
mai das geht die arbeit nie aus morgen
müssen auch die kinder wieder im
restaurant antraben
[Musik]
montevideo ist die neue hauptstadt
unserer uruguay auswanderer
hier mündet der gigantische rio de la
plata in den atlantischen ozean
tag für tag arbeiten susanne und ruhe
die auf ihrer baustelle doch sie haben
gelernt sich kleine auszeiten zu gönnen
ab und an genießen sie das leben der
großstadt verbinden das nützliche mit
dem faszinierenden
hier finden sie alles was sie für ihre
prosa brauchen wenn es auf ihre
einkaufsliste steht ein waschbecken für
die gästetoilette sie entscheiden sich
für die kleinere und pflege leichtere
variante
mit der apa
in uruguay ist das leben entspannter
franco franchi alles schön mit der ruhe
wie es in ihrer neuen heimat heißt
der millionenstadt sich großeinsatz
es ist aussage
die machen es aber etwas ruhiger
montevideos gastronomie ist auch
inspiration für susannes restaurant
ende oktober war erneut schluss für
kunst küsten imbiss kein lockdown
sondern saisonende
[Musik]
doch das leben der familie ist nicht
ruhiger geworden
im gegenteil die fünf katzenbabys sind
da und halten die familie auf trab
und da war ja noch was saschas
geschäftsidee mit dem wendigen
imbisswagen sie wurde realität der
küsten imbiss on tour ganz alt aussehen
bei mallorca was der user unter mit dem
gemeinsamen projekt küsten indes on tour
haben sascha und kevin auch im winter
eine verdienstmöglichkeit
aber das ist das ist okay
das haben wir eigentlich im griff und
elektrik
das teilte biggi welche die bewegung
noch interessant ist neben würsten und
pommes saschas verkaufsschlagern bieten
sie neu raclette an
morgen ist premiere das brot dazu ist
hausgemacht von brigitta probephase wenn
man zuerst vielleicht machen wir viele
portionen geht's und kammermusik mit dem
riesen maschine haben so viel da oben
schon relativ hoch aus setzt amg
abermillionen glücklicher tag für tag
standen sascha und brigit hinter dem
grill haben gebraten und frittiert
viereinhalb tonnen pommes ging diesen
sommer über die ladentheke verleidet ist
sascha dabei nur eines das einzige
wollen die macher asse ist das ist die
einzige straße alles andere
foto stadtrat karl otto muss das gut das
ist eigentlich okay optimale pizza pizza
oder pommes ist doch wurscht hauptsache
die ganze familie ist beisammen mikros
bruder ist immer so ein loch in den
familien axsionics ist und jetzt halt
ohne dann würde durch soziale würde so
vereint und das ist schön
und vor allem löst erasmia vom schaffen
dass das machen auch die oftersheimer
ist und so ihre auswanderung war und ist
ein familienprojekt der starke
zusammenhalt war in der kroner zeit
wichtiger denn je
aber ich glaube im endeffekt was zählt
ist das muss nicht zum kern gehört wenn
man das nest hat auch crooner hatte man
wolle das nicht machen so das ist was
hat man schon mal diskutiert
untereinander und mir jetzt so und ich
glaube dass kronawetter irgendeiner
monsanto und und jetzt mit dem motto mit
leben aber man hat ja nicht so schlag
geschafft
[Musik]
es ist sonntag und wie er ahnt ist das
bauerncafé bestens besucht
das café würde 130 gästen platz bieten
gegen korona aber dürfen die all my das
nur gut die hälfte bewerten
[Musik]
bis 11
die beiden jungs robin und andré
verdient sich mit dem abwasch ein
kleines taschengeld
[Applaus]
[Musik]
auch auf den tischen liebendes trinkgeld
dürfen die jungs behalten
widmen damit will man so viele stunden
voll kunde und jedes stück vom kuchen
möglich das gab nichts womit ihre
stabile erklären in vancouver und da war
trinkgelder teilnehmen oder das
angerufene schnitt ein anderes
aber für mehrere versuche sich binden
das gilt nur während des sommers an den
wochenenden die 14 jährige sophie erhält
das einzige der kinder einen richtigen
lohn 50 kanadische dollar pro tag
sie hat einen wichtigen job sie verkauft
gepäck über die gasse josefs
portugiesische putin törtchen sind
bereits zum klassiker avanciert ich habe
aufgehört mich der unter druck setze ich
mache einfach verstauen
mit unserem café halt hier und will den
zuschauern ganz tag in der küche stand
nun vor denen mache alles was die
familie almeyda anpackt scheint
aufzugehen
[Musik]
abendstimmung am rio de la plata vor
über einem jahr haben zusammen und ruhr
die ihre heimat im emmental den rücken
gekehrt
trotz ihrer kinder ihres prächtigen
hauses und der vielen guten freunden
sie haben den fokus ihres lebens noch
einmal komplett neu ausgerichtet wenn es
aber noch nicht getan mit dem rasen
[Musik]
gleich neben dem edk von montag bis
freitag ist der standplatz vom küsten
imbiss und uhr an den wochenenden halten
alteingesessene budenbesitzer den platz
besetzt
im angebot der dauerbrenner würste und
neu der schweizer hält raclette auf brot
für sechs euro
[Musik]
da hast du eine frau bist zum mitnehmen
ja muss nun ist das zu hoch
dies ist sowohl für die kunst und säbel
zu tun
es ist voll zu decken
dazu unser es auch gleich aber jetzt
sprache für uns zum probieren weil man
kann einen sehr schnell heiß machen
bevor und runter
wir sollten doch keiner interessiert
sich für den geschmolzenen käse nachbarn
dreh war immer eine große unterstützung
für die familie kunz vielleicht beißt er
an
raclette
[Musik]
der kopf
zum glück weiß der norddeutsche nicht
wie eine portion raclette auch
mundgerecht serviert werden könnte
sehr gut
danke die nächsten kunden bekommen die
portion mit holz spießchen noch ist
verbesserungspotenzial vorhanden
[Musik]
für die nächsten boom und die beiden
haben glück während des zweiten lok
downs dürfen sie den wagen offen halten
[Musik]
die blue sea beach
während andere unter der woche arbeiten
müssen können sich die alba das dann
frei nehmen 15 autominuten von
modellbahnen liegt das weite offene meer
freunde haben die familie zum
badeplausch eingeladen
für mich stimmt es eigentlich ja
mich hat's jetzt lohnt sich aber wohl
nicht mehr vorstellen sind noch nicht
ganz abgeschrieben der kontakt mit
anderen modelle der sehr schönen dingen
und dauern drei gelandet und das langsam
erkennt ist dass die soziale kontakt
immer mehr und stört heilig sagt liefers
kommt an der straße waren und es je gab
absolut
[Musik]
für jeden gibt es einen schönsten ort
auf der welt
beatrice und josef haben den mut gefasst
und sich aufgemacht um jenen ort zu
finden der am besten zu ihnen und ihren
träumen passt abenteuer auswandern
jedes jahr ziehen schweizer und
schweizerinnen in die welt hinaus und
wir begleiten wieder einige von ihnen
hoch hinaus an der nordsee 120 jahre
alter wasserturm ist die zukunft von
familie k bus aus dem emmental 40 meter
über der stadt im ehemaligen wassertank
sollen ein café und ein bed and
breakfast entstehen
voller elan starten die kapo saß mit
ihrem projekt
doch das vorhaben ist komplizierter als
gedacht
die auflagen der behörden sind streng
alles verzögert sich in ruanda wollen
die an und marco schober aus dem kanton
solothurn ihr eigenes fitnessstudio
eröffnen mit einem container voller
sportgeräte verlassen sie ihre heimat
nach langer suche finden sie passende
räumlichkeiten in kigali
der umbau geht voran
doch der erste planungsfehler ist auch
schon da leider vergessen kleine kapsel
nichts machen
vom fitness club allein können die
auswanderer aber nicht leben als zweites
standbein pflanzen sie zitronengras an
den sand setzte vom bodensee ans
mittelmeer im sonnigen spanien wollen
corinne und ralf waldburger ein hotel
für hunde bauen
während warme für das vorhaben der
ostschweizer scheint auf gutem weg
[Musik]
plötzlich beginnen die probleme
die baubewilligung lässt auf sich warten
und auch die nachbarn wehren sich
komisches gefühl wenn du und dann kommt
die korona krise spanien steht still
sitzen auf wandern auch sie aus dann
melden sie sich bei uns
auswandern hat saf punkt ch auf und
davon
mit der mobile versicherungen und
vorsorge